it's been almost three years since that
deadly fire at the Alpine motel in
downtown Las Vegas six people died and
more than a dozen were injured at the
property located on 9th Street near
Stewart now a new chapter for the
downtown neighborhood and its residents
this is different people different
energies different Vibes yulika Royo has
been working at this corner grocery
store in Downtown Las Vegas for the past
two years she's witnessed firsthand the
growth of the neighborhood which
includes the deluxe Lofts with this one
opening up hopefully more okay the
property near Stewart and 9th also means
a new chapter according to Residents
after a deadly fire in 2019 consumed it
six people died and 13 others were
injured the Alpine Motel fire
investigation revealed it all started
when someone was using their stove for
heat the fire quickly spread filling
other apartments with heavy smoke
criminal charges were filed against
property owner Alonso Orozco accusing
him of involuntary manslaughter and
negligence Orozco filed several lawsuits
including one where he blamed others for
the fire last year the property sold and
is listed online as Deluxe Lofts
offering three different floor plans as
workers finish up at the new property
neighbors telling us they hope something
can be done to remember the six victims
as they welcomed new neighbors just
positivity you know no more like
throwing trash you know just keep your
neighborhood nice safe calm Collective
orozco's legal battles are still pending
we can also tell you that we did reach
out to the attorney who represents the
victim's families for comments but we
did not get a response meanwhile the
deluxe Lofts are expected to open
according to their website early next
year